hey guys what's up this is andrew for
10senses.com so this is my first video
since i've arrived in france i arrived
three days ago i got some issues as
usual with my flight that got cancelled
you know because of the new coved
variants so we're gonna discuss all of
that but i'm very happy to be here
friendly my gears got stuck at the
custom that's why i only have for now my
personal computer i don't have my
screens i don't have everything but i'm
still here to make an update guys on amc
and i must say
and on jimmy as well i'm gonna do the
two uh stocks in the same video because
uh there are a lot of things to say i
want to make an update on the global
market as well on the crypto market as
well this is all related guys all right
so
we're going to focus today on amc and
jimmy first
and see what can happen so let's get
into
[Music]
it right guys so so i must say guys when
i was traveling of course i was checking
you know on my phone what was amc jme
doing what was the global market doing
and
i was very sad to see that we basically
broke from the triangle we broke out on
the downside guys so we're gonna start
with amc daily time frame first a lot of
things to say guys a lot of things to
say we first gonna analyze the price
action the technicals then we're going
to try to understand
what has actually created this move down
once we know the reasons we're going to
be able to try to assess if this
will keep happening or not so first
technicals guys like i said we were in
this triangle so i was expecting a one
two three four five following eliot wave
theory that was working pretty well in
the past year on amc
so you know when something is working
well it makes sense to keep applying it
and see what information it can bring so
here what we had for those who are
watching my videos you guys know that i
was expecting one two all right that are
complete already we did the third and i
was here expecting a false wave inside
this triangle that would be complete
once we break out on the upside from
this triangle but what happened guys is
that we broke out on the downside so
here we had the first move as you guys
can see that closed just below this
triangle lower band around 36.8 and
after that we opened just below the
triangle lower band which was kind of
the confirmation and then we moved down
very very sharply so first the reason
behind that of course it's not an amc
related problem it's coming from the new
violent uh omicron which is basically
not really under control we don't know
if the vaccine is going to work again
this variant or not so you know it's
creating a lot of trouble in the global
market not only amc
so basically every inflated asset has
seen dramatic outflows in the past week
so this is the reason why i want to
discuss as well the other assets because
we're going to have information coming
from that as well but first here on amc
we got this massive massive move down
minus 15
this was uh when i basically arrived
guys in france i checked my phone i was
like come on
what is that what is happening but it is
what it is so we need to face the facts
and try to understand where it's coming
from and see once again what can happen
after that and first here to me we got a
lot of stop losses that got triggered a
lot of
different investors were or are in the
amc trade and all right apes i'm not
using stop loss uh that's true but the
other investors the big money players
they do and here they all got out of the
trade so they push the price lower and
to me the good thing is that they're out
of the trade so now either they come
back in the trade and so they're gonna
help to push the price higher like they
did before like during this this move
during like
you know basically when everybody was
talking about amc big asset managers
they jumped in the trade so they would
do it again if the situation is again
similar to what it was one year ago so
this is what we want to happen
uh i think that this is what will help
amc price action to be back
in positive territory we need some good
news about this variant because of
course if the comic crisis intensifies
again people won't be going you know in
the cinema everything is going to get
closed again they're going to be
lockdowns everywhere it's starting like
uh already in europe quite a lot in many
countries in france not yet but we are
hearing that you know the president is
gonna say something in a couple of days
and we expect that there might be a
lockdown so of course it's not good guys
for such companies like amc another
phenomenon that to me is happening is
that basically every asset that got
inflated when i mean inflated
i mean that which value has gone up very
sharply in the past year those assets
are the first that professionals are
gonna get rid of this is how it's
working all right they check
what has gone up a lot and they are all
right i'm gonna get rid of that first
and then see what is happening so this
is the reason why we got this uh massive
outflows on amc and gme i'm gonna
discuss jimmy very soon so right now do
i still believe a fifth wave will happen
the answer is yes but
we need to be aware that it might take
some time uh this move down below the
triangle is i mean delaying everything
we are still actually in a triangle so
this triangle is valid
but
it's broken so we need to update the
situation so let me do it right now with
you guys and i'm not sure exactly so i'm
gonna keep this one so
up
okay
and i think that 24 is the level guys
that's where we're gonna find support i
was talking about 24 already quite a
long time ago and right now
as you can see guys when i do this new
trend line here this new triangle
as you guys can see it can last much
longer so
i'm here taking kind of the worst case
scenario
and
we might see you know something like
this okay so this is the new bullish
case when i said the new bullish case of
course
i cannot be 100 sure it will happen but
i do personally believe in that and the
main reason is that i think things are
going to get back to what they were the
fed is gonna start to print money again
uh and this money would need to find a
home just like it was the case after the
covet crisis so right now we have a big
dip like i said i want to show you guys
my analysis of the global market as well
because there is a lot of information to
get from that but i'm gonna do that in
another video my analysis on bitcoin
also shows me that we need some time
guys right now to recover from that i'm
talking about one month maybe six months
so same thing for amc guys it can take
one month in the best case scenario we
find support at 24 we bounce back to the
triangle upper band and in the best case
scenario we come here and we break it
right away so it's going to be graphene
jan 22. this is the best case scenario
and then we might develop and do the
fist wave another scenario that is still
bullish on the long term but that is
just gonna take more time is that we
keep you know doing this little waves
inside here so of course this counting
would need to be redone guys it might be
something like this okay and this is you
know this is the little game of trying
to anticipate what will happen is that
you need to adapt when you have this
kind of information
everything it needs to be reassessed and
right now i think
this is my preferred scenario
so of course there is also an
alternative scenario guys i'm here to
tell you everything of course once again
i don't know what will happen i'm only
trying to you know use past information
especially the most recent past is the
most important and try to anticipate the
future by assuming the same things will
happen because we're going to have the
same players in this market once again
who are the players we have hedges that
are shorting amc so they were here
probably putting a lot of pressure on
the press action we have apes that you
know are holding for a very long time
and that are just increasing their
positions on this kind of moves and we
have you know the other investors all
right so asset manager institutional
clients that big money players and those
guys they are very helpful for the press
action to go higher so we know who is
playing we know roughly how they behave
and like i said asset managers they
won't get in this trade
for some time right now this is what i
believe so that's why i think it will
once again be delayed but eventually if
things come back to what they were we're
gonna have the same phenomenon happening
again and those asset managers they're
gonna come back they're gonna come back
when the the time is gonna be you know
good for them so probably when the
variant will be under control and things
might develop again in this way so would
the target change let's check guys let's
check all right so we're gonna apply
elliot uh fibonacci projections applied
to the bottom of the four swept so right
now we have a false wave that is lower
it's not changing much it's not changing
much because you can see that if i put
it here i'll have roughly 135
so the 1.618 is the fib projection that
is the most likely to happen for a fifth
wave that is extended so this is why it
was my target right now my target is 130
all right so we are losing five points
but especially we are losing six months
i think three months maybe i don't know
so what i'm gonna do guys uh i don't
have my option uh here but basically the
option market is for now exactly the
same nothing much happened there and
the gen 22 expiry is coming guys and
this is where we have the 145 strike so
we're gonna need to see if it's getting
rolled or not if yes
then we are exactly in the same
situation if not then we have a problem
so we're gonna see that uh within a
month all right let me do jimmy guys
quickly bam so not good as well so a bit
the same situation we have this triangle
the difference with gme is that we have
this breakout and you can see that
despite the breakout so we have
everything for us we have the breakout
we have the strong moves we closed above
the bollinger upper band which is a
signal that is used a lot by momentum
traders let me show you that okay here
you can see we closed above during a
breakout so this is very bullish so i
was personally very bullish i personally
lost some money here guys i got uh codes
in this boot trap on gme and on amc as
well but it is what it is uh they're
gonna be better times i'm uh very sure
of that but for now we have this almost
perfect boot trap and right now guys
we're not looking good let's be
very honest here let's try to just
examine the facts and the facts are that
we just broke
out below the
triangle lower band
so what is usually happening after that
is exactly what happened yesterday so
strong move down but i'm afraid this is
not over guys all right we gonna see so
just you know be prepared if i'm wrong
i'm happy to be wrong but just be
prepared that we might see something
like this guys all right and we might go
235 145 some something like this it's
unfortunately what i think will happen
uh because once again we broke out below
the triangle lower band so we can check
the previous lows as usual and usually
this is where we're gonna find support
this is where we have buyers all right
and it's 135 145
so
we have as well one 165 but it's it
seems to me too close to the lower band
so i think that we need to find more
liquidity sitting lower once this
happens we're gonna be in the same
situation guys we're gonna need to make
an upside breakout for now the trendline
is not clear let's be honest i don't
have any clear trend line so
i'm gonna see how things happen for now
this is the best i have so we need to
come back to those higher levels it will
take time we're gonna analyze the short
term press action to see whenever we get
out from the short term bearish trend
that is for now happening buzz and
control so
once we have the first bullish signals
then you know things are gonna start to
do better and i'm gonna keep updating
you guys of course with everything so i
hope you enjoyed this video and once
again i'm going to make an update on the
global market i'm going to make an
update on the crypto market on the rates
on the vix i'm going to show you
everything that i've been taking for the
past two days that is going to give me
very good information about how the
investors are analyzing what is
happening with the virus which is the
main problem here so that's it for today
and if you enjoyed this video please
guys don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're to be the
first to know when i upload anything new
and stay close to show i'll see you guys